this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk which houses
a collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
this episode jonathan is finally taking
a look at the weapons of respawns battle
royale apex legends what the heck is
going on there so we've opened up the
gun and we've shoved a thermite grenade
and then that is somehow super heating
something and then that makes the
bullets
do thermite things
not a clue doesn't make a lick of sense
but it's quite cool
if there are any other games guns or
mechanics that you'd like to see
jonathan take a look at make sure to
subscribe and let us know in the comment
section down below and if you enjoy this
kind of content make sure to keep an eye
out for our upcoming new series loadout
a show where we take a look at the
history and impact of some of the most
iconic weapons in gaming from the m1
garand and the desert eagle through to
the minigun and the ak-47
naturally jonathan will be making a fair
few appearances over on that show too so
be sure to check that out right let's
take a look at apex legends
that's a very interesting looking design
we've got some kind of proton pack
looking electrical cables and widgets
and griebly's on there the thing i
noticed not right away but pretty
quickly was there's a weird kind of
inverted flipped ak selector
lever it looks just like an ak safety
selector lever kind of stretched and
slapped on the other side of the gun on
the left side i think someone thought
that that was a visually interesting
component or control rather and wanted
it on their design but it's it's kind of
um distracting because my brain is
geared to spot stuff like that so it's a
little distracting for me
and then we've got alien halo style ammo
counter as soon as we go into first
person view and we've got indicators for
rate of fire currently on full as in
full auto presumably we're about to see
and ammo high
don't know if that relates to capacity
let's let's find out
okay so we have got a few other styling
cues from the ak kind of and that's
actually that is why having seen a
picture of this thing why i chose the
bullpup ak that's behind me there this
this is the chinese type 86s
which is a commercially offered
self-loading rifle essentially it's
similar in the it's a bullpup ak
but it's pretty far removed we've taken
the kalashnikov they've thrown it into a
blender and this is what's come out so
we've got an ak cocking handle ak
selector safety that is in the wrong
place and couldn't work we've got wooden
furniture which i think here is a direct
reference to the wooden furniture of the
ak not this one but the traditional ak
and it's called vk 47 so it's pretty
clearly meant to be some kind of hyper
futuristic ak weird in that it's so far
removed from the ak that it may as well
not have any aka lineage you could
easily un-ak it but it is kind of
interesting that this is
wanting to anchor itself to that iconic
firearm and if you look at the icon on
the screen you can get you can see the
the top cover the back which is your
only outward indicator that this is a
kalashnikov although that big curved
magazine for many people is an iconic
feature of the ak
right next up we've got the the hemlock
i know that because it says hemlock
series on the magazine now this this
really does look like someone's been
squinting at pictures of an fn scar
similar coloration black and olive drab
or desert tan especially at the rear the
buttstock the way the buttstock slopes
off just the general configuration of
the thing does is reminiscent of the
scar but it's so different in detail
every single detail of the thing is
different they haven't carried over any
specific components or even angles lines
it's just an overall impression of what
a descendant of the scar might look like
and i suspect that's what they were
going for something that does make it
look more futuristic is the very large
magazine well now we don't really see
that on real real world infantry rifles
except where there's a grenade launcher
unit mounted to them that kind of
artificially extends the depth of the
magazine housing but it really does make
it look a bit futuristic compared to
most guns where frankly you want the
minimum amount of metal or polymer to
support and guide in the magazine you
don't want it sticking out the bottom it
makes the gun bulkier when the magazine
isn't fitted and might make it harder to
get the magazine out it's less likely to
drop free if there's more material for
it to get caught on on the way down or
friction to slow it down
right it looks like we've got two
different
ammo counters on this we've got a
readout on the back of the gun which
would be very hard to see when you're
actually using it but i guess why not
have it the gun has got power at all
times and it's robust and doesn't add
weight why not have it on there but then
for actual aiming purposes within your
peripheral vision in fact not even your
peripheral vision within your vision but
not focused upon by your eye is a bar
that shrinks and changes color the lower
your magazine gets in capacity that's
intriguing i've not seen that done
before and i think if we were ever going
to incorporate a visible round counter
in something like a military firearm as
a ready reminder of the status of your
weapon you know does it need to be
tactically reloaded in in some way that
seems plausible to me more plausible
than big glowing numbers because
soldiers either count their rounds or
they're certainly supposed to in the
british army or they will conduct a
check of the weapon if that counts
that's the sort of vague indication is
sufficiently reliable and doesn't
accidentally show you that the gun's
empty or full when it isn't i could see
that being integrated
okay i'm getting a distinct family
resemblance vibe to some of these this
kind of makes sense so hear me out
in the car in the world of um modern
cars we've had convergent design where
your typical family car ends up looking
much the same regardless of who's
producing it and it's surprising if one
breaks the mold and looks a bit
unconventional and i think we're going
that way with firearms as well there is
a an aesthetic fashion element to
firearms design as there is for
everything else there are even some
designs that have been designed with the
with the outer look first the tavor
quite famously was sketched pretty much
on a napkin before it was before they
then worked out what to put in it to
make it a gun if that makes sense and i
don't see why that wouldn't continue to
to diversify initially to try and
diversify
for the market so people see something
distinct but then as soon as one
manufacturer tries to follow a design
cue you end up i think converging back
down on everything looking the same
something like this
where they all work voice in a very
similar way but they look radically
different i could see it happening that
way
right next up we've got a spacey
reinterpretation of something like a
minime or maybe more accurately a
knight's armament stoner type machine
gun something something of that nature
so seeing this actually run it behaves
like a beltfed weapon and it looks like
an lmg the magazine feed device thing is
very bulky potentially there's a very
compact belt folded away in there i
don't know if it's meant to be belt or
magazine bed now the only difference
there would be whether there's a spring
in the magazine in in the container that
feeds or whether the mechanism of the
gun is dragging a belt of rounds into
the gun and as it's entirely enclosed we
can't tell that now what does
conclusively say magazine is there's no
top cover there's no way to open the gun
and feed the belt in then again this if
this has got like servo motors dry you
know dragging ammunition through the gun
maybe you wouldn't need a top cover they
clearly wanted hybrid between an assault
rifle and an
lmg in a modern sense and then project
that out into the future and then we've
got this utterly bizarre devil
head
thing
on the back of this particular modified
version what can i say except you know
anything that adds weight is not usually
desirable
what the heck is going on there so we've
opened up the gun that apparently does
fire bullets from a sort of
drum mag at the back and we've shoved a
thermite grenade which i've seen being
used in the game the footage that gets
shoved into the action somehow even
though bullets have to get from the back
of the gun to the front of the gun so
i'm not sure how that would work and
then that is somehow super heating
something looks like the barrel is
getting super heated and then that makes
the bullets do thermite things
not a clue doesn't make a lick of sense
but it's quite cool let's see what
damage it does
right so the effect is fairly subdued
there's not a great deal of
incendiary effect that i'm seeing there
it just kind of as it says on the
indicator there revs up your uh
conventional ammunition now regardless
of feed issues shall we say heat is a
massive problem for firearms now i'd be
less concerned about that if this game
didn't use conventional
self-contained metallic ammunition with
brass cases if it used some futuristic
ammunition system i could get my head
around it a bit better i'm guessing the
guns have some sort of cooling system
built into them this one must because if
your cartridge gets red hot as we're
seeing here you know thermite's damn hot
really really hot that's how it works
burns down through things what happens
is the round goes off and you don't have
to hit the primer in the back of the
case to set it off if you
leave it in a fire or shoot it in a very
hot gun this is this is why machine guns
are typically open bolts so that there's
air able to circulate and stop what's
called cook off where the round just
blows up because if that happens before
the bolts locked the gun will explode do
it damage potentially do you damage so
deliberately applying super heat to your
firearm is a bad idea
all right so this i don't have to kind
of stare and squint and work out what
the inspiration might be for this this
is very clearly an m14 or like an m14
ebr in space it's even got the what
would probably say springfield armory on
the receiver at the back stamped into
the metal we have the same thing here
but it says las tumosa armory chula
vista i think i think it is california
under that now it's not a 3d model of an
m14 that they have abstracted and
redesigned they've designed it from the
ground up but with some very direct
references to the m14 and the role is
the same dmr designated marksman rifle
now the original m14 role was infantry
rifle or what we might now call a battle
rifle so this isn't so much based on
that original infantry version of the
m14 long barrel wooden furniture shotgun
style stock oh this does still actually
have a shotgun style stock just a very
sci-fi looking version of it with a
cheap piece shortened barrel but cape is
still capable of enough accuracy and
crucially to deliver seven six seven
point six two nato level firepower out
to medium range six to eight hundred
meters something like that now this
isn't doing six to eight hundred meters
in game because ranges in games are
inevitably contracted probably the most
grounded gun that i've seen in the game
and the only one realistically that you
could recreate if you wanted to we're
using an m14 as the basis for it
all right nice another nice sci-fi
design here bullpup dmr now it says
triple barrel marksman rifle there are
multiple barrel rifles one or two made
for just because they could the
manufacturer could and people would buy
them for fun essentially and then a
couple of
trials rifles over the years the idea
being to effectively combine the effect
of a shotgun and a rifle by giving you
rifle range and ballistics with a fixed
spread of shot at a distance so so one
easy way was to increase the number of
bullets in the cartridge and then they
did look at dual barrels
for the salvo program as well there is
precedent for this but there is no
successful
military rifle
that uses two or three barrels because
it the barrel is a large amount of the
weight of a given firearm so you'd
better be getting some seriously
important effect out of the thing to put
two or especially three barrels into it
[Music]
right not what i expected this is some
kind of an energy weapon magazine fed
still i guess the magazine contains the
some sort of projectile is it
electromagnetic is it plasma i don't
know it's very cool though and i really
like what they've done with these three
barrels now with a conventional firearm
three barrels would make it far too
heavy with some kind of energy weapon
and the right technology and materials
let's pretend that it doesn't add much
weight and it means that you get either
a spread of
shot meaning that you've effectively got
a shotgun or if you hold it down the
three barrels somehow converge on one
spot and you get all three bullets
hitting hitting uh approximately the
same place so like a weird combo of a
dmr and a shotgun they're doing
something different
i like it
another very sci-fi looking design the
side mounted magazine um brings to mind
well things like the gephard
anti-materiel rifle the neo pup 20
millimeter again an anti-material rifle
and perhaps that's the better comparison
because this is clearly meant to be a
very man-portable non-crew serve type do
you know is it an anti-material rifle
now you can you can run a barrett on
your own as well
people have proved that so it's only any
stance to reason something like that
would get lighter and more wieldable in
the future as well however what's a bit
odd and goes against this being a
futuristic amr is the manual operation
very clearly in the game to balance the
very high
power of the gun incidentally i like the
bullet shaped round counter on this one
there's no reason why this would be
straight pull um it should be self
loading if anything self loading tends
to reduce the felt recoil on the shooter
because it slows down how how long that
recoil takes to hit you essentially but
it's a cool design um and you know
you've got to offset the capability of a
weapon somehow either get either make it
one shot only and even more powerful or
give it a magazine and make it
straightforward action
this is a very strange design at first i
thought this was some form of revolver
if you look closely enough or you
perhaps know this already if you play
the game it does have a reloadable
ammunition unit i hesitate to call it's
definitely not a cylinder because it
doesn't turn it's not a magazine i guess
it's an on-block clip let's go with that
it's essentially a block of something
that has three rounds set into it but we
seem to be getting more than three shots
out of it so the gun opens up you slap
that in gun closes up and these are very
small shot rounds now there are shop
shells for pistols revolvers not so much
for self-loading pistols because they
don't you won't necessarily function the
gun reliably they're usually used for
revolvers here with your essentially
chamber of three shots
yes that could work but you're
inevitably think of the space in there
your shot are going to be absolutely
tiny and the only real world use for a
shot pistol of this small caliber would
be defense against snakes that's what
they're used for in the real world maybe
for keeping
vermin down rats that kind of thing as
well but this is something new different
i don't fully understand it but i like
the fact that they are trying something
different with it
a sort of unholy hybrid here of a break
open shotgun a lever action shotgun and
some sort of space gun because we've got
a lot of glowing blue stuff here
electrical crackling electricity along
the barrel housing thing and a blue
ethereal glow when you eject the clip i
think it is i think it would probably
technically be but it is firing shot so
whether there's an electromagnetic
assist going on or that's how they're
accelerated and there's no gunpowder
don't know but it does go bang when you
shoot it regardless of all of that i
have no idea why it has a lever why you
would need a lever to cycle rounds that
are already in the chamber other of
course than just
looking cool
the wingman helpfully marked on its
replaceable cylinder obviously is a
futuristic magnum type revolver slightly
curious operation in the top and the
bottom straps i guess you call them
mechanically open up to facilitate
reloading i'm not sure why the bottom
one needs to open for that to happen and
in fact if there's enough room for the
cylinder to revolve i'm not sure why you
need the top strap to lift up either but
it's a vision you know visual interest
thing i i assume now that raises the the
classic question
of why bother um i don't you know it
doesn't matter how futuristic this
revolver is it still can only fit six
rounds in its cylinder we have you know
standard pistols compact pistols have 15
rounds in the magazine now so why would
you compromise with six you'd better be
getting armor penetration for some
reason some kind of enhanced
power that a self-loading pistol
couldn't handle for whatever reason
doesn't really make sense
as always um if you'd like to support
the work we do here at the royal
armouries have a look at the description
for this video and you find out how to
do that either way i'll see you next
week
[Music]
you